foreign
[Music]
this is Star Talk Neil deGrasse Tyson
here your personal astrophysicist
today's edition is a cosmic queries on
the subject of invisibility we all want
to be invisible at some point in our
lives and I got with me my co-host Nagin
farsad Nagin welcome back hello Neil I'm
so excited to be here and to be talking
about this crazy topic it's a crazy
topic and for those who who are meeting
you for the first time on this show all
right your host of fake the nation okay
you've got a podcast of your own there
and you're also a regular on wait wait
don't tell me I think I've been on that
twice and I didn't do very well they
asked me questions I got them all wrong
they never invited me back and yeah they
usually help guests just get the
questions right so they must have had
something against you in particular not
to help you
they usually rig those tests yeah but
it's a delight full moment of
conversational comedy uh in wait Wait
don't Tell absolutely on NPR of course
it's still on NPR absolutely yes
excellent and you're also a host of
recently the succession recap you know
I've seen episodes of succession I don't
want that recap okay it's too weird it's
too it's too I don't know what's going
on or why or should it be happening I
don't understand it I don't want to
understand it and you're going to recap
it I mean Neil you have no idea these
Recaps are like just out of control we
are we get so deep into the psychology
of billionaires it is fun ridiculous and
we have no idea what we're talking about
because none of us are billionaires no
it's tune in for the family in the
family tensions and everything I don't
want it yeah okay
all right so I've read a little about
this but we have people out there who
are experts
in invisibility and we're not talking
about the CIA or anybody like that we're
talking about
we're talking about actual physical
Optics of invisibility and so we comb
the landscape and we found Professor
Greg Gaber Greg welcome to StarTalk
hey thank you great to be here a
professor of physics and Optical
Sciences at University University of
North Carolina at Charlotte so your
research focuses on classical Optics
the wave nature of light so classical as
opposed to Quantum Optics I guess is
that how you distinguish that yeah
that's exactly it light is a wave not as
a particle
um and so you're not in denial of it
being a particle are you just saying you
you care about it when it manifests as a
wave and you're good with that
yeah that's about correct
um I find the I find the wave properties
just really elegant and beautiful and
fascinating and even though we've known
lights away for like over 200 years
there's still so many interesting things
to discover and your author of a book
that just has an audacious title
invisibility let me get the title right
here the history and science of how not
to be seen oh my gosh released in 2023
so this is you're the right guy for this
I'm guessing I hope so yeah
all right so so Nadine we we've
collected questions from our patreon
members now the the the barrier of Entry
to become a patreon member has been
reduced so you can actually have access
to our questions and be not only special
recordings of our questions and answer
sessions but also you get to get one of
your questions submitted and that's for
like five dollars a month which I'm sure
costs less than all orders of coffee you
could possibly put in Starbucks I'm
pretty sure is that right in the game I
mean absolutely well yeah and that
includes tip I think I think right
totally totally okay so what so what do
you have for us Nadine okay so Dylan
um from Flagstaff asks this question
sounds weird but can you be invisible in
other spectrums of the electromagnetic
field it's one thing to be invisible
from visible light but how about
ultraviolet or infrared I love that yeah
and let me just preface that
um Greg by saying you know technically a
window is invisible right because you
can't see the window if you see what's
on the other side of the window the
window's just kind of not there
so this whole thing of invisibility
could you just put it on some kind of
foundation so that we can know how to
think about the questions that are
getting asked
sure I mean I do draw usually a
distinction between transparency and
invisibility so a window is very hard to
see and we all know that in a lot of
cases you just can't see it at all but
how clumsy you are yes yeah yeah 10 year
old Nagin definitely didn't see the
sliding glass door that she walked into
really more embarrassing so embarrassing
so embarrassing well now I feel bad
because when I give talks I often use a
gif of people walking into like glass
doors to highlight the point
um but so so we tend to think of Windows
as transparent because they always do
for in almost every circumstances
reflect a little bit of light
and when we tend to think of
invisibility we think of something that
isn't going to reflect light and it
isn't going to disturb the light that
passes through it or around it so that
the object becomes in principle
undetectable for whatever spectrum of
light you're considering
all right so visible light this
questioner clearly knows about other
bands of light in the electromagnetic
spectrum and I'm I'm happy to I'm always
jumped to point out that
windows are transparent to visible light
but are almost opaque to infrared light
right so if our eyes were tuned to
infrared wouldn't the window just be
opaque it'd be like a wall is that a
fair statement I think so yeah yeah okay
so now in whatever you do to make
something invisible like give us an
example and then tell me how you might
do that in a different band of light so
what's your favorite band of light to
render things invisible well
you know I'm always partial divisible
but okay
come old-fashioned facts
partial to visible right I'm a
traditionalists none of those fancy
waves for me
um
so actually I one thing I can say is
that the first experimental test that
somebody did to try and demonstrate at
least the principles of making an
invisibility cloak they did it for
microwave wavelengths which are longer
wavelengths you know closer to the radio
wave spectrum than the visible spectrum
and they did that because the
wavelengths are longer it turns out it's
easier to design the structures that'll
do this light guiding and hiding of a
hidden region
wait a minute Greg Greg
microwaves that's what police radar guns
use
so can I make my car invisible to the
police radar gun
you know I don't want to you know I
don't know Neil what are you trying to
get away with there what is going on it
sounds like this guy knows he's never
paid a ticket in his life okay no go on
dang I mean you just gave me a new
application
crime right and one that's surprisingly
plausible actually
um because the the little structures you
need to design to fabricate sort of an
invisibility cloak and microwave ranges
are more on the order of millimeter size
structures or centimeter size structures
which is a lot easier to do than to try
and make
structures for visible light which is on
a billionth of a meter scale of the
wavelength kind of thing oh you're
saying your tools and and and your the
bricks you're using to make the the
object you know the the construction
elements have to be on the size or
smaller than the size of the wavelength
itself
that's exactly right
um and that's a great way to put it is
sort of little building blocks because
and if I could already jump in to use
the technical uh attention catching term
metamaterials
um cloaking device is an invisibility
were part of this what they called a
metamaterial revolution the idea that if
you mess around with the structure of
materials on the scale of a wavelength
you can suddenly get all sorts of
optical behaviors that you don't get in
a material in its natural state all
right so what's an example so now you
you meddle with my material and then I
become invisible what hap what did the
light do that was behind me that now
comes straight to you to make you think
I'm not standing here
oh yeah so the kind of the traditional
invisibility cloak the traditional first
one again you had one of these the
traditional classical so classic yeah
the old old times
old-fashioned okay go on
there you go these are the ones that
people first introduced in like 2006
theoretically and those the idea is you
design your materials such that they
guide light around a central hidden
region and kind of like the analogy that
they often use is like water flowing
around a rock in a stream the idea is as
the light goes in it takes a detour
around the hidden region and then it
goes on its way exactly like it came and
it goes out the way it came in so that
in principle you don't know it took that
detour
um and you keep saying materials are you
like as essentially talking about
the ability cloak am I allowed to say
cloak on this podcast
I think you can okay
right was that a term before Harry
Potter like the visibility cloak yeah I
don't know oh this is one of my favorite
little mind-bending things or at least
for my mind
um that when I was researching the book
I was kind of going through scientific
papers trying to find the earliest
examples I could of scientists talking
about invisibility and
I suddenly happened upon a paper from
science news and I think 1942 or so and
it was titled cloaks of invisibility
well there you go and my heart literally
skipped a beat I was just like
I thought I was going to like rewrite
two-thirds of the book and kind of
refigure everything out but it turned
out they were talking about just regular
camouflage
you know hiding hiding things in
camouflage having somebody hiding in a
spider hole under the ground okay and
that's and that's a warped wartime paper
as well yeah right 1942. I see so so
you're not invisible you just no one
notices you
yeah right
that that's where you get kind of for me
I always I kind of say that you have to
be careful the word invisibility is
incredibly suggestive and Incredibly
vague
so Nadine have you ever seen those
people who have painted into a pattern
on the wall yeah no totally that sounds
like what that book was about exactly
and only if they moved only if you move
do you see them but right position
themselves just right all the patterns
of paint they just disappear into the
wall yeah yeah I've seen models do that
and others you know who don't mind
people painting on their bodies you know
this sort of thing all right so so Greg
what you're saying is you can do this in
principle for any band of light it's
just easier for longer wavelengths of
light that's what you're saying here
that is exactly it okay
the longer the wavelength the easier it
is to make the fundamental building
blocks you need to make to kind of
construct the light guiding material
okay so you just say this like of course
you can do this with the material so
what precisely are you rearranging
at the you know at the level of the size
of of your bricks to enable the light to
go around it the way water goes around a
rock okay well this is where it's I
still have a hard time coming up with a
good example that visualizes it but I'll
give a historic example which is the the
founder of metamaterial theory is John
Pendery and in the late 1990s he was
contacted by a company that was made I
got to interrupt the way you say that
I'm thinking he's in the late 1800s no
the late 1990s
dude I was alive then right that was
still the 1900s you know what I mean it
was a long time ago now dude I was alive
then give it a little more respect than
that please we still had landlines so
um so what happened is this company
contracted John pendry they said we made
this great new paint and it's made out
of carbon
and it's really good at absorbing radar
waves but we do not know why it does
this
and the radar is microwaves right
basically yeah or longer wavelengths
um
and and that was sort of the funny thing
is they made this great material the
only problem is they had no idea why it
worked so they brought in pendry it was
this condensed matter theorist who
looked at it and pendry realized that
you know naturally we tend to think of
carbon you've got Diamond as one form
you've got graphite is another and he
found that the carbon that they had
fabricated was on this very small sub
microscopic level a bunch of Tangled
little threads of carbon that were all
woven together and Tangled Up and I tend
to describe it that the radar waves
kind of hit this Forest of carbon and
get lost in it and then they eventually
get absorbed
and that was sort of the Revelation that
hey just because took the cut took the
carbon and instead of just having it in
this sort of natural graphite form they
scrambled it up into this Tangled mess
it suddenly had very different Optical
properties so this would be good for a
stealth airplane coatings
right they don't reflect back the radar
at all just absorbs the signal so you
don't even know it's there exactly okay
that's a form of invisibility once again
yeah right and I suspect that I suspect
that the company that Pedro was working
with that the material that they
discovered is probably very similar to
what's used in stealth aircraft but the
people that do the stealth aircraft are
talking so right so we don't know
well let's get another question see if
we can slip one in before the break from
James Myers um
um let's assume we have a full spectrum
cloaking device if that device consumes
energy wouldn't it show up in the
infrared oh I love it oh
what kind of audience do we have I mean
they're smart it didn't even occur to me
that a thing would require energy like
some sort of energy consumption but if
you're going to absorb energy you're
gonna get hot period that's pure
thermodynamics so yeah Greg what about
that
that's the sweat
yeah uh two things I could say about
that one um well yes uh let's start with
yes uh that's one of the interesting
things about sort of what has happened
with cloaking research as as the years
have progressed now is that people start
with these really idealized models of
invisibility cloaks and then they
started to realize that there were all
sorts of limitations to these idealized
models and all these practical
considerations and yeah infrared
radiation would be a very big
consideration
um if your object is ending up hotter
than the surrounding environment you're
probably not going to be able to
completely hide it that way
um
but uh one thing I can mention which is
kind of mind-boggling in and of itself
is people have theoretically speculated
that you can actually apply some of the
mathematics of cloaking to the equations
of thermal heat flow as well
and they've theoretically said you can
make a thermal cloak that
uh heat diffusion works heat diffusion
works very different from the way waves
propagate but the equations are close
enough you can kind of adapt it you can
design an object that kind of keeps the
heat away from the middle of the region
for for a period of time I mean Super
thermos like like air conditioning for
an object is that kind of uh kind of
more like a do not enter sort of barrier
that it's sort of just that it kind of
It kind of forces the heat instead of
the Heat going into the middle of the
region it goes around the region first
and it eventually kind of seeps in not
exactly the same thing as hiding
infrared radiation but but if you
redistribute it that way you can you can
in fact you could probably create the
shape of something that people would
think is not dangerous to you yeah yeah
if you you can sculpt something out of
the radiate that's interesting well when
we come back we're going to talk more
about going invisible on Cosmic queries
with my co-host negin farsad and our
special guest Greg Gaber who is a
World's expert on going invisible when
start talk continues
we're back StarTalk Cosmic queries the
invisibility episode Whoever thought I'd
say get to say that we've got an
invisibility expert Professor Greg
gaberner professor of physics and
Optical science at the University of
North Carolina Charlotte and of course I
got Nadine
you got all the questions for us I
ugly and and um should I just dig right
in yeah yeah just give me another one
from Tom B Knight we have a sort of
foundational question
something in
visible to the
net expectrum
so just nuts and bolts how do you do it
so yeah based on what you've already
told us Greg it sounds like you're only
restricted to one part versus another
can you take out every part of the
electromagnetic spectrum that's
something you could do
that's actually been one of the big
challenges in invisibility even trying
to make something invisible to the whole
of the visible spectrum turns out to be
a bit of a challenge there would be red
all the way through Violet right yes
invisible wavelengths yeah yeah and
there's kind of one thing we could say
is there's a practical challenge which
is that in order to make it invisible to
all parts of the spectrum you'd have to
make it a cloak that
has properties for every wavelength
separately and the light's all going to
propagate a little differently
um
there's also a fascinating fundamental
issue which is that this goes back to my
picture of a cloak Guiding Light around
a central region and sending it on its
way
well that means the light's taking a
detour through the material and that
means that compared to all light that
would have just gone straight through
the light that takes the detour is
taking a lot is going a longer distance
however so in order for it to be truly
undetectable it's going to have to go
faster than light that went in a
straight line path all the way through
now the problem with that is if you're
trying to make an invisibility device
that works in air the speed of light and
air is pretty much the speed of light
and vacuum which means that your
invisibility cloak would have to have
the light be going faster than the
vacuum speed of light in the cloak so
what you're saying is just if I re recap
you're saying for the light to go around
the object and come out the other side
and you have no way to detect it it has
to come out the other side at the same
time it would have come out the other
side without having to go around the
detour exactly otherwise there's a time
delay from that blob of light relative
to all the light around it but why would
you even notice that
well you would actually note you would
actually notice it in an image at least
some some way Downstream of your light
beam because there's this delay and the
light coming out it would act kind of
like a lens what a lens does when it
focuses is it delays part of the light
selectively to the other which gives you
some sort of curvature so if you have
this time delay imbalance that's
effectively going to give you some sort
of focusing effect Greg can I just tell
you as a person with regular eyeballs
maybe this puts you at ease I wouldn't
notice you know what I mean if that
light was just like a touch slower I'd
be like cool that light's doing its own
thing I'm not here to judge take your
time whatever you got to do I just I'm
here to look that's it you know yeah
that's that's there you go there you go
you get good enough people with messed
up eyesight no one's going to notice
that's what you say
that's actually been part of the trend
in a lot of the invisibility research
since these sort of early theoretical
papers as people said well you know
we've been talking about can we make
something perfectly invisible and in
principle it's possible in practice
there's a lot of problems but we don't
really need something perfectly
invisible if we make something 90
percent invisible
um that's probably going to be pretty
good or 99 or something like that that's
people walking into play class Windows
yeah yeah yeah
okay but not to put words in your mouth
but if you were to make the getting back
to the question if you were to make the
entire electromagnetic spectrum
uh invisible through an object then
you'd have to have materials
serving every band of light in that
electromagnetic spectrum because they
the one there's not there's no one
solution fits all so that would be a
problem it would be a huge
surface a very thick skin around the
object because every layer of the skin
is going to handle different wavings of
light differently is that is that a fair
statement that's yeah I think that
pretty much hits it exactly
okay so you usually don't see people
looking at sort of super Broadband
um
invisibility cloaks they're really happy
right now if they can study a cloak
that'll you know block or make invisible
some parts of the spectrum and try to
learn from that so I tell people you
know the is it the B2 bomber which looks
like the bat plane that has I've read
the radar cross section of a bumblebee
right so you're looking for this bomber
and nothing's showing up all right and
however you could just go outside and
look up
because it's not it's not stealth in
visible light it's only stealth in radar
light right and so I
so it will matter it can matter
ultimately right what you have to know
how they're trying to detect you to then
be prepared for that
exactly okay I'm just going to verify
verify all right Nadine what else you
got for us
um well I have from from Chris plots he
writes if invisibility
when did that mean that someone who was
made invisible would be unable to see in
the spectrum that bends around them I
suppose another type of invisibility
where the image behind a person is
projected in front of them would get
around this but that itself but that
itself would only work against people
probably in a pretty narrow band
directly in front of the invisible
person they'd be obvious from the sides
seems like invisibility as issues man we
got good people out there
what happens to the person being made
invisible can they see anything
well if the invis that if I the way I
say it is yeah the invisibility cloak
works as intended then yes nobody can
see you but you can't see anything
so that's like the least fun superpower
I don't even know it's I guess you can
eavesdrop pretty great but you can't see
anything that sucks
yeah they're they're kind of a couple
workarounds of this so the question the
questioner is correct yeah the person
would not be able to see outside of
their own eyeballs in the wavelength
that you're using to make them invisible
yeah yeah that's crazy that's crazy okay
and I mean there are a couple of
workarounds and science fiction authors
have done a good job of this too one
workaround is you simply have some sort
of detector or sensor and now we start
now you start to imagine a vehicle
instead of you know something you're
wearing on yourself a periscope of some
kind yeah that that detects and you know
infrared or ultraviolet that in a
spectrum that's not being shielded
okay now another thing that people have
proposed and I should stress that a lot
of this is all
if it's been done it's been done on a
tiny tiny scale so
um we're not talking about somebody
looking over your shoulder right now
without you knowing but
um people have also proposed that you
can you can actually build the the cloak
the cloaked structure as part of your
invisibility device if you know if you
know how your
the thing you're trying to hide is
scattering likes you can design your
cloak to cancel out that scattered light
it becomes a wave interference effect
so you can kind of in principle design a
cloak where you get some of the lighted
as a detector but the cloak itself has
been designed to account for the fact
that part of the light has gone inside
and there for what
well
ideally the cloak itself is now invis is
still invisible because it's blocking
any of the lights scattering off of you
but some of the light from outside is
coming in to where you can see it oh
okay all right so this would be a
solution to that problem yeah okay
how far are we from this being available
at h m just for purchase in the back
corner
yeah ponchos invisibility cloaks and our
and does the cloak have pockets I mean
just thinking about practicality here
a quick question
um one thing um though I I always go out
on the limit I always get these things
wrong it's really hard to predict right
now it seems like
it's really really hard to try and make
something perfectly invisible with this
cloaking sir in this cloaking sort of
sense so I'm not sure whether anyone
will ever completely get it to work in
practice
um it might just be too hard and not
worth the trouble to try and assemble
these building blocks to make this thing
though somebody will still probably try
um
and they'll probably still be some
limitations like we've talked about I
use that to reassure people because when
I tell when I tell them I do little work
and invisibility you know they can start
to worry that I'm dooming us all but in
fact if you had perfected it how would
we know yeah
we would never know
my skating coach keeps telling me I need
to give her an invisibility cloak and I
keep telling her I already gave it to
you don't you don't see what it is
she can't find it okay all right so
you're the author of the newly released
book
invisibility the history and science of
how not to be seen so uh so is that out
yet at the time of this recording uh the
the book just was released on April 11th
of this year April 11th 2023 okay
excellent in the game tell me what else
you got well we have from Kayla Hunter
the question
um in The Avengers movie they had a
Helicarrier that turned completely
invisible in this scene it looked like
the ship was covered in a layer of
individual panels that caused this
visual effect once the stealth mode was
activated what's the science behind that
and is it possible with the technology
we have today to execute something
similar so this is like a switch you can
just turn it on and make I think James
Bond had a version such as this whereas
Aston Martin could just on command could
go invisible because of something on the
skin so have you have you researched the
the authentic physics of these
documentaries called The Avengers series
science documentaries uh a little bit I
can say yeah
um and here I can distinguish between
what we often call passive invisibility
versus active invisibility and passive
invisibility is where you design the
structure to guide the light but you
don't mess with it you just let the
light go around the hidden object and go
on its way and so the object just sits
there and the light just does what it
does active invisibility is this idea
like the James Bond car like The
Avengers
um actually like the 2020 Invisible Man
movie where the idea would be you'd have
a bunch of cameras on one side and on
the other side you'd have a bunch of
projectors and so
if you have the object completely
surrounded on one side it'll always be
taking in the scene it'll a computer
will process it all and put it all out
on the other side
now one trick with that is it's a little
more difficult than a lot of people
would think because
um you know when you take a photograph
we get the still image of a scene but if
you're trying to recreate the actual
True Light field that's hitting the side
of an object you don't just record how
much light is it in a location do you
know which way the light is coming from
um and this is kind of like the person
who talked about the projection image
the questioner earlier that you can
project an image on somebody and it'll
look correct from One Direction but if
you step two feet to the side it doesn't
look good anymore right because you're
not capturing the entire reality of
what's going on on the other side which
is every light beam from every angle
coming in interesting so and it wouldn't
be a projection I wouldn't think in this
these modern times the side coming
towards you would just be clad in some
high resolution pixel LEDs or something
right isn't that what that would be yeah
then the the projection that comes out
the other side would also have to
project light and all these different
directions you know each picture with
pixel would be recording light coming
from all these different directions on
the other side it would have to send
them all out on other different
directions let's close out this segment
and come right back for Segment three
after this break and we're talking about
invisibility
not only now but possibly in the future
and even in science fiction when Star
Talk returns
we're back Star Talk Cosmic queries the
invisibility episode with Professor Greg
burr from the University of North
Carolina Charlotte and of course Nagin
farsad uh Nadine I also saw you I said
this last time but I just want to
recapture my emotion when I saw him
channel surfing and there you are on TV
chilling with Hillary Clinton yep yeah
just just remind me what show that was
um Hillary Clinton and Chelsea Clinton
have a show on Apple TV called gutsy
women and it's about gutsy women
um they wrote a book about Gussy women
in history and then the show is attempt
to to kind of show gutsy women who are
alive
so it was if you wrote a book called how
to make white people laugh that's gutsy
yeah so I it was one of the honors of my
life you could check out that show on
Apple TV okay and what what captured
their interest was it your book how to
make I mean it was it was probably my
book and it was partly I I've sued um
the Metropolitan Transit Authority in
New York City
um for the right to put up funny posters
about Muslims I've done a lot of work
around like activism comedic activism
um around immigrant rights and
islamophobia um and so that's something
that I think uh caught their interest
wow well I didn't know any of that about
you okay I'm multi-layered okay I'm not
I'm not wearing no invisibility cloak
there's a lot going on here exactly you
were invisibility cloaks that's a
different point
um so Greg I'm gonna have to call you
out on this right now okay you're so far
you've been all talk
oh I wouldn't do this and I go to
materials and I got we talk about that
have you built one of these things yet
have you or are you just Mr theory yes
burning question
yeah darn you already called me out on
the theory part I can't use that as a
defense
um making like the the cloaks as people
are trying to do them is actually very
difficult and people have made some
simplified cloaking devices the biggest
one I've seen was big enough to hide a
cat
which may be very big yeah
um but it was also an imperfect cloak
now one thing that I have done is and I
wish I brought it and I wish I'd thought
of doing that is you can do a very nice
light guiding trick using prisms and I
guess it's a classic trick that a friend
introduced me to you put together eight
prisms in just the right way and this is
sort of me using my fingers as the top
view and the light rays will reflect off
the prisms and do a detour around the
central region
so you can stick your hand in the
central region you can stick your
fingers in there you can but while
you're looking through the prisms you
can see everything on the other side
oh I see so the light is internally
reflected within the prisms as it comes
around the curve that's exactly it it's
total internal reflection so all of the
light is perfectly reflected inside and
it's not it's not really an invisibility
cloak the way that we would like to it's
a fun Optical trick yeah yeah and it
demonstrates that idea that yeah we can
send light around a central region and
it'll still work very convincingly by
the way Greg I love that your friends
are showing you like you know Optical
tricks
um because my friends are the type of
people that are teaching me to take
Alka-Seltzer when I have a hangover so
two I need to hang out with your your
friends I mean you need people who have
eight prisms in their pocket right right
that's what you need exactly
all right and again you got another one
give it to me from Christopher Bax
um they write can you explain a bit
about what the interaction between light
and matter is that makes some
wavelengths of light reflect off matter
and other wavelengths pass through for
example visible light reflects off skin
but x-rays can look through it are there
existing or theoretical materials that
would not interact with visible light
and would be visible to the naked eye
I love that yes so what's going on on
the surface this is this is all a
classical wave Optics right for you yeah
yeah and
yeah and so first of all with x-rays
part of what happens with x-rays is
there's such high energy
uh particles if I dwell into the quantum
oh for a moment he said light with
particles
[Laughter]
my whole life is a lie
warning
no no in all fairness to him uh as an
astrophysicist we want to detect objects
in the universe that emanate in all that
that radiate in all these different
bands of light and it turns out it's
more sensible to reference high energy
light as particles and low energy light
as waves right so no one thinks of a
radio wave particle radio particles we
don't think of it that way and it's hard
to think of gamma way or x-way x-way or
x-wave
um so so the fact that particles slipped
out of your mouth is very consistent
with anything I have to think about when
we talk about band of light and
detecting them but go on yeah and and
have a little historical side note on
that but I can come back to that in a
moment
um otherwise the um provisable light
part of the trick people actually
including my own research I did my PhD
work on
brood invisibility in 2001 before it was
cool
um and
okay sorry go ahead when you said crude
invisibility yeah food okay so like as
opposed to refined yeah yeah like the
modern invisibility theories are really
elegant and powerful and you can do all
this stuff back in the day I was doing
very primitive versions of that sort of
stuff back in the Arts and the odds yeah
I remember it one else we were young and
innocent then back in the Arts yeah on
three okay go on
um so back then there were it was widely
thought that you couldn't make things
invisible and part of it was this
reflection problem that there didn't
seem to be perfectly reflected perfectly
non-reflecting materials that would be
non-reflecting for any direction that
light's coming in
um but people found out and demonstrated
or or at least rediscovered that if you
make the right material that has and
I'll get a little technical has a
magnetic response in addition to an
electrical response and also is what we
call an anisotropic material then you
can design materials that don't reflect
any light at all even even if their
Optical properties are different from
air light can just go in without
reflecting and that was a big piece of
making invisibility work
all right and so
but what was the question the question
was about explaining about the
interaction between light and matter
um yeah so if light so if like it's
absorbed and doesn't get completely from
all angles but x-rays go straight
through you yep so why aren't they
interacting with our skin the way
visible light is yeah and that that goes
back to the particle thing that x-rays
are so high energy
um you know they're kind of
what do you what do you use as an
analogy for something just going through
right through you without stopping a
freight train going through your body it
just charges right through yeah there's
nothing an x-ray is so high energy it
just for the most part doesn't interact
with anything in your body and it just
goes straight through because it's got
so much energy and it's so out of
it oscillates at a frequency that is
much higher than any of the frequencies
that the atoms in your body are
oscillating at so they don't even notice
each other at that they don't yeah right
they pass in the hall they don't talk
um and so that's the advantage of x-rays
is that they're they just are so high
energy they don't interact with matter
very well because yeah I the best way to
describe it is this frequency difference
atoms tend to have these natural
frequencies they vibrate at
and it so happens that those natural
frequencies they vibrate at are
comparable to the frequencies of visible
light so we see a lot of stuff x-rays
have super high frequencies very
different from the frequencies at which
atoms are vibrating so there's very
little interaction so so it's
fascinating to think about it that way
that means for any two things to
interact at all there's got to be some
resonance between the frequencies
otherwise it ships passing passing each
other in the night that's that's a lot
of the way it works yeah okay pretty
cool I'm learning a lot like these that
what these all these wavelengths are
very standoffish
hard to be friends
you know that's right yes they are you
got to get you just have to know the
right frequency no no you have to be on
their wavelengths same difference it's
the same concept right all right well
Tom lindellius actually writes from
Sweden
um he asked would it be possible to
light a room in such a way that
everything in it would appear black and
white about 15 years ago my physics
teacher claimed that it was possible but
she never told me how to actually do it
oh I think so
I think so let me take I'll take a stab
at this Greg so if you know in advance
what color everything is
okay
if you known oh black and white yeah oh
okay I'm thinking of something different
because what's very cool is if you get a
very deep red light for example like one
of these emergency lights that are light
a hallway and you take a Coke can
a red and white Coke can and bring it up
to that lamp
you cannot see the White Stripes
because the red reflects the red light
and the white reflects the red light so
the whole can just turns red
and you can do fun
light experiments this way and if you
take that cocaine and put it in front of
a deep blue light
the red only knows how to reflect the
red blue it's going to absorb it you're
not going to see any like that turns
black
the re the white turns blue and the can
becomes black and blue
so it's the weird thing is the color
something is is not what it absorbs it's
whatever comes back to your eyes and if
nothing comes back to your eyes it's
black now that's my starter here Greg
can you turn a room into only things
that are black and white
by choice of wavelength of Illumination
that I don't know if that's possible you
can do that I'm not sure I've never
really thought about it before I think
he might have been on the right track
that if you have a room that has only
certain colors in it you might be able
to tailor the illumination to sort of
selectively
ignore or reflect or absorb you find a
frequency that's not represented by any
object yeah and then all of those colors
turn black yeah however that frequency
would be reflected just as itself from
anything that's white yeah so the
everything that's white would be the
color of the light everything that's not
the color of the light would be black
but you wouldn't get white because if
you got white at all the white has all
the colors and it would show you the
colors of the stuff that's turning black
so I don't believe I don't believe your
science teacher
was a lying no yeah but also I
like if you
if you do basically we're talking about
Instagram filters here on like a room uh
uh like in a three-dimens like in real
life then you'd be rich Greg maybe this
should be your next venture is how to do
Instagram filters in real life that's
you know that's Greg you know you missed
out hey you just did the three of us
just form a business Maybe
so in the game one last question that
might be all we have time for if that
here we go from ten Advanced smells more
um from Atlanta Georgia they rate of
invisibility cloaks work by bending or
manipulating light and if we can see
into the past due to the time and
distance it takes for light to reach us
then might it be possible to make time
invisible
oh yeah
oh I actually do have a good answer for
that
and in a in a sense which may not be
exactly what the uh questioner is asking
people have made what they call time
cloaks
and what they did is so you picture you
picture this picture that I made where I
said okay there's this hidden region
there's a cloak around it and the light
goes around it like that and so imagine
this is like the horizontal position
this is the vertical position replace
one of those axes with time
and now at least in a picture you've
made a Time cloak you could make you can
design a structure where it kind of
hides events in a certain time regime
from light
okay now you sound dangerous
now I don't you know I worry about in
the game I don't know I know the main
message I think for all of us is that
Greg is is we should all be very scared
right now okay he's a very dangerous man
especially of Greg yes people
occasionally say that about me and then
I say but I am kind of lazy so it all
kind of balances out oh there you go a
lazy diabolical uh uh Nemesis to the
superheroes yeah yeah well Greg has been
a delight to have you and the next time
you have a full up cloak that they can
sell in h m uh
you want to come back and tell us about
it
but it's a delight to get this kind of
insight because we've seen it discussed
and we've heard about it but we didn't
know people were actually doing it so
good to know that you exist in this
world and again great to great to have
you again oh always fun to be here and I
about a visibility cloaks this was a
dream for a whole show that's right all
right
this has been start talk Cosmic queries
the invisibility episode from Neil
deGrasse Tyson here keep looking up
thank you